who's that giant dead creature and the
big question what's up with Jane Foster
keep watching as we dig into the small
details that may have flown by in the
411 Thunder trailer at the very start of
the teaser there's a short sequence
showing Thor at various stages of his
life interestingly Thor's costume
changes dramatically as he shifts from
child to teenager to adult and it would
appear that the teenage Thor is actually
wearing his original costume from the
comic books specifically he appears to
be wearing the outfit that artist Jack
Kirby created for the character when he
debuted in 1962's journey into mystery
number 83. this iconic look saw the God
of Thunder sporting a red cake but
sleeveless blue vest black and yellow
striped boots along with a gleaming
metal Helm with wings on either side
this continues the endurian MCU phase 4
tradition of finding ways to get Heroes
into perfect replicas of their original
Silver age comic book costumes a scene
in the Garb worn by Scarlet witch in one
Division and classic Loki and Loki oh
and that Spidey costume at the end of no
way home too
as Thor is working out with some pretty
hefty chains he's sporting an outfit
with a rather humorous nod to Thor
Ragnarok what really stands out about
this outfit is the fabulous trucker hat
that has the world's strongest Avenger
plastered across it and the font of the
original Avengers logo MCU fans will
remember this moniker from Thor Ragnarok
when Thor tries to activate the quinjet
by placing his hand on the scanner and
submitting his name for voice
recognition
strongest Avenger access denied
strongest Avenger access denied
soon after Bruce Banner aka the whole
cops on board and signs in as the
strongest Avenger this time the nickname
is accepted it's definitely a blow to
Thor's ego that the Hulk is the biggest
and baddest and it looks like by the
time love and thunder comes around he
still hasn't gotten over this perceived
slight
the trailer offers a quick glimpse of
Thor and his Rock buddy Korg in a snowy
Bridget landscape as they gaze upon the
massive corpse of a creature that looks
to have been absolutely fearsome in life
for comic book fans the appearance of
this Behemoth should come as no surprise
director taika ytt has lovingly
recreated the spitting image of a comic
book panel from Thor God of Thunder
number three depicting poligar the
patron god of the galactic Frontier
despite his scary appearance falgar was
a friendly acquaintance of Thor's his
Slaughter then is a clear sign that the
film's big bad Gore the god butcher
played by Christian Bale is already
killing deities
when you've got a Villain Like Gore the
god butcher it stands to reason that
love and thunder will have a lot of
deities popping up for Gorda butcher one
God that might be a particularly high
risk is Zeus the revered ancient Greek
ruler of Olympus but the trailer coyly
hides who's playing him Russell Crowe
has been confirmed as playing the king
of the Greek gods with no clarification
as to just how much he'll be appearing
in the film judging by the teaser it
could be a prominent role Thor looks to
be paying a visit to Olympus perhaps to
speak with Zeus himself about the threat
of Gore we can see Crow's take on the
character basking and praise of his
subjects will Zeus share similarly stoic
characteristics to the dearly departed
Odin or is this father of the Greek gods
going to be a more haughty arrogant
figure party Thor from what if might
hang out with prepare yourself
for the party Prince
Zeus's demigod son Hercules is a major
Marvel superhero in the comics and even
an adventure so whether he appears in
this film or not Turk is almost
certainly on the way
after all the pain he suffered in recent
films Thor is now very much on a journey
of self-discovery and Enlightenment as
Illustrated in the scene where he
meditates under a tree and many
mythologies and religions trees are
closely associated with themes of
knowledge and self-discovery Norse
mythology has its very own tree
Odin is granted knowledge of other
Realms and runes by hanging himself from
one of each cell's branches for nine
days and nights we also see Thor
planting his branch-handled ax
Stormbreaker on the ground much like one
would a sapling Stormbreaker then fires
a bifrost beam on Thor's Vikings
spaceboat it seems that Thor's tree is
meant to Grant him valuable knowledge
and abilities to hop between Realms
maybe even the Realms belonging to other
gods at the end of Avengers end game
Thor leaves new Asgard to go off of the
Guardians of the Galaxy and he names
Valkyrie the ruler of this new home for
Asgardian refugees
it's time for me to be who I am rather
than
who I'm supposed to be
but you you're a leader despite all
their loss yes Guardians have persevered
and when audiences last Saw knew Asgard
it appeared to be a small village this
teaser trailer suggests that the town
has perhaps started to thrive under
valkyrie's rule cruise ships appear off
the coast of the city and even a flying
Asgardian Ship Sails over people's heads
a white van marked new Asgard tours
further suggests that the asgardian's
new Hall might have started a thriving
tourism industry Valkyrie however does
not necessarily look thrilled in her
position as new asgard's ruler almost
echoing the now iconic image of Steve
Rogers proving himself worthy the
trailer depicts Jane Foster wielding a
mysteriously reforged mjolnir much to
the original Thor's surprise eagle-eyed
fans will note that the cracks running
through the great hammer signify that
this will be the same mjolnir that hella
so unceremoniously destroyed in Ragnarok
it's still not clear whether Jane or
someone else put the Magical Hammer back
together another big question is just
how much of the Jane Foster version of
The Mighty Thor's comic book origin
story will make its way into love and
thunder because if Marvel Studios adapts
it Faithfully this movie might be a huge
tear-jerker in the comics Jane is
diagnosed with cancer before being
deemed worthy of wielding mjolnir the
incredible power keeps her illness at
Bay but it also purchased her normal
body of her chemotherapy each time she
reverts back to her usual self we'll
have to see how Faithfully the story is
adapted when Thor love and thunder hits
theaters on July 8th check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more Looper videos about the MCU are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]